Isabelle Floren qu'est-ce que vous
pensez vous est-ce qu'il faut passer à
la contrainte je pense que enfin c'est
compliqué de passer à la contrainte ne
serait-ce que pour le Parlement mais il
faut quand même remettre les
dispositions contraignantes de quand
nous avions voté il y a 2 ans et pour ça
il faut quand même une majorité je suis
pas sûr que le gouvernement les très
clairement sur ce sujet après deux
années de covid et de contraintes mais
avec des textes qui permettaient de le
faire donc pour le coup je suis pas je
suis pas si sûr de cette possibilité à
l'heure actuelle c'est pour ça que le
gouvernement pour le moment fait appel à
la responsabilité et c'est bien on
constate que c'est compliqué je pense
dans les transports pour le moment ça
vient mais difficilement on verra bien
comment le mois de décembre se passe et
je vous dis il y a une contrainte
législative qu'il faut quand même une
majorité pour faire passer ses mesures
et pour le moment
je n'ai pas de sentiments que le
gouvernement
comme si rien n'avait été fait je ne dis
pas que le système est on en a
conscience va pas bien actuellement
qu'il y a des problèmes des urgences qui
a les problèmes de la pédiatrie à chaque
fois il faut le dire récemment encore le
ministre de la Santé a remis en place un
plan pédiatrique connaît quand même pas
mal le sujet il était médecin urgentiste
sur la table sur le Ségur de
revalorisation de salaire qui sont qui
ont été mis en place dès 2020 grâce aux
Ségur ce plan se poursuit effectivement
il nécessite et c'est le travail
notamment du Conseil national de la
refondation sur la santé qui se passe
sur le terrain avec l'ensemble des
professionnels de la santé dans un
certain nombre de départements pour
trouver des solutions parce qu'il y a
des expériences qui marchent parce qu'il
faut optimiser surtout tout le lien
ville hôpital permanence des soins ça
j'aimerais bien entendre Marine Le Pen
c'est vrai que sur ces sujets là on
l'entend jamais ni à l'Assemblée
nationale ni ailleurs il y a pas de
points
en accusation permanente le gouvernement
de ne rien faire ce qui est faux
d'ailleurs puisque il y a un certain
nombre de mesures qui ont été votés il y
a des possibilités et il y a un débat
qui se fait sur le terrain mais sur ces
sujets je peux vous le dire et je suis
des débats l'Assemblée nationale on
attend vos propositions en dehors de
l'aide médicale d'État et Madame de guar
raison c'est vraiment une obligation de
toute façon que vous soigner des
étrangers sur le territoire et c'est un
devoir d'assistant qui est prévu au
niveau européen notamment mais à part
ces sujets là quels sont vos
propositions c'est toujours le même le
populisme connaît c'est dénoncer ce qui
va mal effectivement le secteur de santé
fait partie
c'est vous vous enfin vous comprenez que
ça fait un peu brouillon quand même
aussi de l'extérieur cette communication
à écouter Arlette Chabot et Françoise
Debois oui je pense qu'on gagnerait
quand même aussi en sobriété de parole
en fait
c'est vrai que c'est con en fait entre
guillemets séquence médiatique sur ces
sujets la réalité c'est que dans
l'opinion derrière ça bon en dehors de
l'angoisse il y a un vrai sujet il y a
un vrai débat il y a des parlementaires
d'ailleurs qui travaillent sur le sujet
et la question du nucléaire et la
question réelle de notre capacité de
notre souveraineté énergétique et
derrière il y a des vrais sujets mais
mériterait qu'on les pose ces sujets là
et que les politiques les posent
vraiment et qui ne se laissent pas sans
arrêt happer mais je sais que c'est
compliqué par par les questions par le
quotidien par la petite phrase par un
coup je rassure un coup j'inquiète les
gens derrière ils éteignent en quelque
part les informations se disent moi je
vais payer c'est vrai ma facture je vais
faire comme je peux et en revanche il
nous pose la question il me pose la
question de l'enjeu pourquoi tant de
centrale n'avait pas été finalement en
maintenance qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
pourquoi on en arrive là alors qu'on
avait cette capacité au départ qu'est-ce
qui se passe là je pense qu'il y a une
il y a plutôt un bon sens que de poser
les vrais problèmes je pense ça c'est un
enjeu des mois qui viennent et des
années qui viennent pour pour nous sur
les retraites Emmanuel Macron est-il
trop jusqu'au-boutiste c'est à VOUS
Isabelle Floren moi je m'exprime en tant
que porte-parole du MoDem et donc je
fais référence notamment à la note qui a
publié le commissaire aux plans qui est
le président du MoDem cette semaine pour
clarifier justement la question des
retraites et la question des retraites
elle mérite pour le moment en tout cas
encore beaucoup d'explications d'une
part pour dire est-ce qu'on pense aussi
au MoDem qui a un déficit qui a un
problème qui a un problèmes d'équilibre
contrairement à ce que disent certains
syndicats et ce que disent certains
partis politiques il y a des équilibres
on l'a estimé et François Bayrou
l'estime un certain nombre d'économistes
à
environ 30 milliards d'euros dans les 10
ans qui viennent au minimum du fait que
l'État intervient pour compenser une
partie de ce système notamment via la
fonction publique notamment via des
apports qu'il fait régulièrement sur des
mesures de compensation donc ce déficit
nous nous constatons au modem qu'il
existe bien mais que la solution
maintenant c'est de prolonger et je
pense que là et gagner la bataille de
l'opinion publique qui est loin d'être
gagnée aucun syndicat qui soutient le
projet pour le moment tel que nous
supposons qu'il va être annoncé cette
semaine donc nous attendons les comptes
aller mais nous sommes pour le moment
inquiets et du moins réservés du côté du
MoDem c'est pas évident non plus de dire
bravo la réforme tout de suite c'est pas
c'est pas bravo la réforme d'une part
parce que autour de la table il y a les
partenaires sociaux d'accord il y a le
gouvernement faut pas oublier qu'il y a
un débat et qui a le Parlement pour le
débat épique derrière il y a l'opinion
publique ça fait quand même 4
entités qu'il faut convaincre donc ça
c'est pas gagné pour le moment c'est
bien que l'opinion publique est tout à
fait à 75 % pour le moment opposé en
tout cas sur une réforme avec cette
mesure d'âge sur les 10 années qui
viennent on sent bien que les syndicats
unanimement pour le moment sont opposés
qui aura un débat parlementaire et que
je connais un certain nombre de
parlementaires qui en l'état sur ce qui
est annoncé pour le moment son contre y
compris dans la majorité donc nous ça
veut dire qu'il y a des leviers que
cette note de François de Bayrou permet
de poser aussi des solutions des
solutions c'est un taux d'emploi
d'employabilité des seniors plus
important
un chômage qui serait réduit à 5%
permettrait effectivement des
cotisations supplémentaires des leviers
aussi sur des taux de cotisations
patronaux tout ça ça mérite simplement
ce qu'on dit au modem ça mérite un débat
ça mérite que les citoyens que les
Français soient aussi consultés associés
il y a des des
consultations qui sont faites mais là
pour le moment si vous voulez l'annonce
d'un plfssr c'est à dire une une un
texte budgétaire pour cette mesure pour
récupérer
du terrain je suis élu locale j'écoute
les gens qui viennent m'en parler
spontanément qui m'envoient des messages
et qui me disent c'est pas possible ne
nous mettez pas tout le monde dans la
rue on peut pas négliger cette
discussion avec les Français qui sont
concernés tous concernés aussi bien les
jeunes que les plus âgés qui vont s'y
retrouver qui vont être à la retraite
effectivement ceux à qui ça convient
plutôt parce qu'on est dans un système
par répartition c'est les retraités
actuels parce qu'ils se disent
finalement vous consolider notre
retraite mais même eux je pense qu'ils
pensent aux générations qui arrivent
derrière eux et comme nous sommes dans
un système de solidarité nationale sur
les retraites méritent qu'on en parle
aux gens il méritent qu'on fasse ce
travail c'est en tout cas ce à quoi mon
parti et au travers la voix de François
Bayrou on essaye de dire sincèrement
sans coup politique pour le moment c'est
vraiment pas le moment le sujet de
discuter et de faire comprendre et au
président de la République et au
gouvernement qu'il faut se donner aussi
ce temps je comprends que la mesure de
déficit est un sujet est un sujet aussi
pour la France vis-à-vis de ses
partenaires européens mais on peut pas
brusquer me semble-t-il c'est ce que
nous disons brusquer les Français qui
n'ont pas encore tout à fait compris ce
qui allait se passer et donc il faut se
prendre le temps encore nous semble-t-il
de cette discussion